welcome back to the games foot stage
here at e3 2017 joining Dave and myself
is Stefan from ivory towers talk about
the crew - welcome thanks a lot firing
me yeah what's it been like I mean they
got like a kind of tease I think there
was a financial report and I said oh
yeah the crew tooth coming and everyone
was like alright that was an interesting
time because everyone in the community
was just like well that's gonna be it so
they went crazy on every kind of ideas I
were just like yeah yeah yeah yeah go on
guys going guys well we have some
something big for use and quite happy
for the reveal today and with the huge
trailer we had and that was crazy
receptions of fossil super happy super
problem I mean it's a very very big
departure from the first game I mean so
the first game it was like driving
across America and having like the good
old American road trip and now it's like
you can drive you can write ride a plane
you can pilot a boat you can do
everything and you can change between
them so where did this come from
from the players actually really from
the players we saw a lot of players
inside of the crew one just having fun
going around so we have that dark story
you know in d1 and that was a bit of a
forced progression but players just
didn't want that they really want to
have that you Japan world the full USA
ready to have fun and enjoy them the way
they want who said okay there's
something there so we reworked
completely the entire playground the
entire USA to allow them to have fun
just basically and so the more vehicles
the more interaction that you can have
with the world the better and every test
that we do right now is super positive
players enjoy the fact that it's more
free it's just just fun you know mm-hmm
but it seems like the the main story now
is it's just to become does that call
king of motorsports yeah think so you
literally just be like I want to be
number one everything it's going to be
up to you man it's just like you want to
do this okay you want to do more
exploration and don't do any races and
it kind it's okay you're going to be
able to progress and earn points and
continue to unlock new content even if
you don't do more racing stuff you can
do more freestyle you can be more
off-road we've opened the gates to every
kind of play style for every kind of
players here
so I mean straight off the bat if I like
you boot up the crew - do you have a car
that you start with you have a plane or
a boat or is the other things that we
have to sort of work through and unlock
or discover by ourselves yes basically
the first five minutes you're gonna play
everything you're gonna play car plane
boat and after that it's up to you
decide you want to do plane right now
okay okay let go you want to play alone
just with planes for your own experience
in the crew - you can it's okay if it's
your kind of fun that's where you're
gonna have fun and we have a lot of
diversity in planes and in boats and in
cars and in bikes
and all that kind of stuff it's just for
any kind of players you know we wanted
to access everything to get access to
everything for all the players instantly
so no more gating no more you have to do
this and this and this before having the
game just like go on have fun
so what challenges was has that brought
taking your vehicles from the tarmac to
huge open sky and then seas and rivers
all across America like how how did how
did you build that after you know being
stuck to the road a lot of work
necessary that was a huge intense work
for the team to recreate and reshape the
whole USA but now for all these kind of
new vehicles so even the Far view the
graphics and shine the render has been
improved to be sure that now when you
are flying through the sky you have this
wonderful volumetric clouds in the sky
you can go through them you can see at
very far view it's it's really a cool
experience that is completely different
from the Kawana and now you go out doing
this and then you can switch to a boat
because why not you know because you see
a river you want to go into the river do
an event into the river go there do it
now it's as accessible as that yeah if I
wanted to be uh you know bit of renegade
could I take a boat and just sort of
like if I'm gonna plane can I just go
boat and then land on the on the road I
mean obvious I wouldn't get very far
yeah but I could do it yeah if you want
to have fun like that you can do it we
didn't put any restriction in this kind
of switch because players like this kind
of situation actually just having a
jumper with a car and then switching to
a plane and then going on top of the
water and switching to the boat
than doing crazy stuff trying to jump on
top of the bridge and we let the players
go we let the players do it because
that's what they want to do exactly
so you've talked a lot about it being
open a lot of people when they think of
a racing game they think of the track of
the black arrows in the yellow
background to take you round corners how
open is your game if I see a hill and a
forest I just drive there can I get to
get to point A to point B no matter like
what route I want to take yeah simple
there seriously it's just as simple as
that yes everything in the game is
accessible either by car by boat by
plane to whatever you want and that
that's it
but we also build some circuits because
we have some very you know pro racing
fans in the in the community so we have
also discovered by a different kind of
disciplines we have we call them the
family so we have a family for offroad
while the family for jet sprinter sorry
for freestyle a family for street racing
and a family for pro racer so those guys
if they want the perfect line you know
beating the circuits the the
milliseconds they have something for you
we have something from them in here yeah
so with these families how are you
ensuring that each family gets like
enough content that will keep them
satisfied we test we test a lot we have
a lot of players doing some play tests
for us since a long time now so we we
check their interests that we check how
they feel with the controller with the
new type of vehicles do the like it is
it's too smooth to too hard et cetera
and we fine-tune fine-tune and we
continue to do that we have a bit of
phases coming very soon for the crew to
where we'll let a lot of new players
play the game give the feedback and it
will do like this and this and this this
is where we have fun also as a team to
really make the game for the players not
just for us as game makers you know the
one of the biggest surprises is when you
showed that first trailer they had the
inception style bending right I thought
that was like that's just a cool
stylistic thing they've come for and you
see the gameplay and the world in front
of you is bending what's happening there
strange behind the wheel what's
happening we had that first idea the
first idea came from for the trailer we
said okay what can we do for trailer you
know crazy ideas flowing in and it's
like okay bending the world can be fun
okay
and then the creative the record calls
me and say you know what we should do it
in game I was just like really man are
you serious want to do that in the game
see yeah that's gonna be very fun and we
tested it we had it in the game I were
just like okay this is so cool this is
just perfect
whoa moment that we can do in the game
that nobody can do you know so we are
just like okay this is this is pure shed
stuff so we need to keep it and actually
the players react really strongly to
that the first time you play the demo
even here at e3 that was like whoa
what's happening what's doing is so
wheels it as a transition for certain
type of event to move from one type of
vehicle to the other little more
scripted event and stuff like that so it
gives more you know how do we call that
it's you know capturing the moment and
some even stronger so don't see that
every moment you don't click and we've
been the world just on demand is a
special tree every now and again it's we
have that here and there and we took
care so far well we're happy with that
yeah so I mean how he chosen how to sort
of bend the world if that makes sense so
I mean in the original game it was like
a huge map of the US and you can visit
all these big cities and famous sites
but now it sort of seems like you know
things can fold in and can you just hop
it like could I be in San Francisco and
the world's just be like alright now
you're in New York well we try to keep
it realistic at some point even if it do
well you know it's just like really like
Mason yeah ya know we really keep that
for certain events during the
progression and the story you're gonna
have this kind of crazy events where you
can you know experience something very
very different and very unique so we
don't put that everywhere in the game
where you want to be special moments for
the players is it gonna be explained in
the game like the main character be like
whoa what's this what's happening here
why is it fun it's like how difficult is
that technically to implement that was a
bit tough seriously that was a bit tough
I still remember discussion with the
tech guys they were just like no we
should have knew that you know it's a
very good idea you know want to do what
yeah studying my data but at the end of
the day we have that tech that allows us
to build that huge
country the USA completely reshaped for
us so we can use some tricks here and
there to really use that at one vantage
so that was really fun at the end of the
day what was the choice behind staging
your game in America was it because
you're kind of familiar with with the
country or was it more of a decision
that America has such a vast array of
landmarks and sceneries you can go to
it's all comes down to a trip we did
with the team in the United States and
to discover more about those new motor
sports rising here and there and we
wanted to really feel how those guys
were living this and we really you know
we call our game motor nation that's
kind of a moto we have in the game this
is really this this is the United States
this is where all motor sports behave
and live and evolved to crazy new races
on an ice lake and whatnot it's just
like it this is this is where it's
happening right now so we had that huge
playground already for the crew one
we've kept it when we decided okay like
how we can make it even better
so we've reshaped everything now in the
city you have jumps going on rooftops of
New York buildings because it's fun and
you know going in through parking lots
are good to find shortcuts we really
reshaped everything in the world just
for the fun of the new vehicles and even
for the existing vehicles to be just you
know fun let's talk a little bit in
terms of so as a player what can I do
like what can I can I just go up to a
family-like event and just take part in
it or is there some kind of story
progression that I can follow or can I
just drive around fly around and just
find my own path so we're going to give
more details in the future regarding
progression I'm sorry I'm sorry now
seriously we have that very open
progression system where you can go into
the for families it's not a choice that
you are stuck in and then you have to do
all the stuff before moving just today
you want to do more off-road okay go
there you're going to do events for the
offroad family tomorrow you're more
freestyler in the in your mood okay you
can go there now have new events new
challenges for you I discover new
disciplines in that family so it's
really open and you
the way you want in that particular
session if tomorrow is different it's
okay you can switch there's there's no
restriction it's more like a support for
people to understand the vast majority
of the you know the variety of content
that we have so we have the families the
disciplines it's there for you to
understand but it's not a locker you
know you just you have your load to do
what you want you want this huge
playground you've got is it is it kind
of segmented in in different areas or
can I literally Drive from the west
coast of America all the way to the East
Coast if I had enough time so you can
drive you can fly you can do it by boat
if you want we created actually a river
network that goes west to east coast
entire breadth again I states yeah if
you wanted to by boat and just have fun
and you can do it well I think we even
did it on north to south because it's
cool because even that doesn't exist in
real life that made sets in the game so
we said okay let's do it because we saw
the players in the crew one doing it
with the bikes and the cars which we
need to support that also for the new
type of vehicles just let the
exploration exist and people embracing
it the wedding one so yeah how long is
that going to take me there five sides
take a road trips from San Fran to New
York that's gonna be around three to
four hours ah constant driving yeah
that's amazing
play right schedule you can take the
small roads the big roads whatever you
want off what if you want yeah another
big part of the first game was obviously
the social features like being able to
group up with my friends and raise how
are you implementing that into the crew
tube so basically we keep the crew
concept as a whole between the crew one
and the crew too so you still be able to
group together form a group of four pick
up four players and do every activity
together so that can be more co-op that
can be more PvP but basically everything
is playable by four so that's the base
that's the crew that's who we are
but we've worked a lot on connectivity
and network between the two the crew one
and the crew too obviously to make sure
that everyone is allowed to group more
easily than we had in the first one so
we really reshape that to be sure that
you know people can embrace it
are there going to be any sort of
bonuses for veteran crew one play
is if they open up in Kuching yes so we
love our community it's just like you
know they'd the lovers would love them
when it's just like okay we thought
about a new system a new reward program
for them so we said okay what can be a
good you know measurement of their
engagement said well we have achievement
so we can unlock you new vehicles in the
crew to watching for you if you haven't
locked certain type of achievements in
the Quran say you are more an explorer
you haven't locked those achievements
you have vehicles waiting for you in the
crew - and that can go up to 18 vehicles
for free waiting for you when you get
the first time in the crew - so it's me
it's our way to say thank you thank you
for playing so hard in the cornea in the
spectrum of racing games I kind of
defined with their like an arcade style
it's for fun and a simulated style it's
like very tactile and very precise where
does the cruise through to sit in that
or have you kind of got elements of both
well we're much more on the arcade style
definitely we don't want to go in the
simulation side there are the guys doing
it really well and they we respect them
for that but on our side is pure fun
accessibility take the pad have fun and
just drive you know drive right pilot
whatever you want now you know yeah so
our card is definitely our main focus
yeah so it's ivory tower the lead
developer the solo developer cuz I mean
a lot of the times its Ubisoft you have
so many studios everyone kind of pitches
in so so we're working yeah we're
working with a lot of people inside of
Ubisoft so we have people from Shanghai
from Bucharest in Romania people from
Paris from even a massive studio in the
in Sweden is working with us that's a
huge team that's the strengths of
Ubisoft here where we can put a lot of
people playing working and playing
actually together sometimes to really
create that huge powerful team to
deliver this kind of impressive scope
you know yeah and in terms of engine
what are you using why using our own
engine that I was already used for the
crew one that we've beefed up the bit
you know and you see now the graphics
that looks amazing the vegetation have
been reworked completely also so we
really push the envelope here yeah so
now the crew one had
hundreds vehicles you did a great job of
really expanding their garage you've
added two more elements that the entire
ocean them rivers in the sky how many
vehicles we're going to be getting in
the crew two more the real answer is
much more yeah okay look figures now we
don't have the real figures right now
because we are still working with the
light sensors and working that huge
lineup that we want to have and as much
as we have all the details we can
communicate on that so far we're still
hard at work on this yeah how is I've
been working with a lot of license like
Motorsports and engines and different
manufacturers I'm guessing there must be
some people that you approach to be like
you want to put our weird vehicles like
helicopters for example not a lot of
helicopters in games we're like
MacLaren's and Fords I'm sure that
they're used to that sort of things you
ever get anyone being like um I guess
but uh helicopter or play in the game
sure well you know as soon as you show
what you want to do with those vehicles
in the game they are just like oh that
can be cool and they understand and we
value them you know we're not here to
destroy their vehicles we're not here to
make them look bad you know so they are
super happy to see their creation inside
of that usual and the players having fun
with them so we really respect those
licenses those manufacturers and the
return the favor they really like us and
we have a very very good partnership
with them now we use the words
destruction are you adding much the wave
destruction physics into your game when
other cars can end up be up if I decide
to drop one off a cliff so we will still
have a bit of destruction on the
vehicles but we were a bit lighter now
because we went very farm the crew one
and even the community was just like I
don't destroy my portions like it's so
beautiful I was like okay okay so now
the destruction aspect is much lighter
because we really want to respect and
understand you know embrace those
wonderful vehicles that we have in the
game so yeah is that also an element of
kind of keeping the fun and exploration
alive you don't want players to be
worrying about destroying their car if
they want to do something
exactly exactly we really want the
players to have fun in the world the way
they want so we don't we removed a lot
of obstacles will be on progression in
the world everywhere it's just like
opening the gates three
the crew seems incredibly ambitious and
huge what's been the biggest challenge
in realizing that vision oh my god
that's a tough question
I don't know yeah recreating the world
for us that was a huge huge huge work
because we wanted to be completely
refreshed so that means a lot of assets
a lot of work to be done on the cities
everywhere the landmarks redone so it's
a huge work but it's a fantastic work
because now we see the result here we
are showing Manhattan I completely
rebuild and everyone is just like that's
not the same as before
exactly that's the point exactly how are
you building your world when it comes to
online am I going to be able to if I
want to take a road trip and again using
the example of San Fran to New York and
a guy across the world driving New York
San Fran we can across paths is it going
to be a whole connected thing or is it
going to be more of a pie base yeah it's
definitely an open world and a connected
upon the world so you can drive solo if
you want never party with anyone but you
may cross all the players we are
sessioning you with other players
dynamically so you always feel that you
are online and you have players around
you if you don't want to do ending the
activity with those guys it's okay
you're going to be able to do your own
experience and if you want to party and
create a crew that's where an extra
level of fun is case is coming so it's
really up to you but you're going to be
always online and always connected to
everyone in the game yeah if I want to
drop into a race with one of my buddies
and say he's in like Central America
like Texas area and I'm stuck maybe far
away I can just be like I yeah I'm here
and if even if he's doing a race with
the vehicles that you don't own it kind
of discipline you don't own we're going
to loan you one and I'd be able to play
it if you like it then continue to enjoy
it and replay it if you want if you want
to buy one and make it you know you have
a progression system around the car with
a leveling system then you can purchase
you know entry level vehicle in that
kind of discipline and then continue to
progress it's really again accessibility
have fun you know opening the gates for
everyone you talk about buying vehicles
is that going to be something done with
in-game currency you earn or is that
going to be a page
micro transaction is it something that's
naturally progressed it's basically both
we we keep the same logic that we had in
the crew on
we have that kind of dual currency
frequency that you can earn by doing any
kind of activity if you want to go
faster you have the patron see nothing
is locked behind a paid walk you there
is no unique kind of vehicles that you
can only get for a patron see we really
give the players the choice and yeah
it's a so far the reaction and on the
crew one has been very good so we don't
want to change anything that works it's
okay
is it difficult to balance sort of the
pay2win sort of aspect you know there is
I mean there is one but is it difficult
to sort of plan to avoid that basically
everything that is regarding gameplay is
not around microtransaction so you
cannot be better just by paying more
it's just impossible in the game
everything is planned as an RPG system
and so if you have time you're going to
progress if you are money you're going
to progress we can you're not going to
be better by paying or not pay you know
it's as basic as that gotta get good
yeah and we have some good players while
doing some tests knock-down they're
crazy good like they're trashing us it's
so bad your best players is it gonna be
like maybe seasonal competitions or kind
of like an eSports element that you're
gonna be looking into to really get the
best of the best in there it's a bit
early to talk about that I'm sorry
sounds like you got a lot more abuse
leave then well seriously yes we're
releasing early 2018 so we have a lot of
things to discuss right now we are
really opening the gates and showing the
game and the huge work that we are
rebuilding and all the crazy vehicles
that we have but it's only the beginning
we have much more to talk about and we
were just like okay can't wait to talk
more about all those kind of filaments
yeah
so it's playable on the show floor here
at e3 yes one of the folks at home gonna
get a chance to play it gonna be some
bases coming I'm English so that really
hurts
today Peters so yeah we already
announced basically a new beta program
beetle that is now open basically you
can register right now and we're going
to announce the first dates very soon
that's going to be you know we like we
like the players we want the players to
test that the game and give the fing
back so we can find some behind so we
can have a lot of different beta phases
coming down
before the release yes so fine thank you
so much for joining us we can't wait to
play thanks a lot for more on the crew
to obviously keep your eyes peeled to
gain sport comm but don't go anywhere
very shortly we'll be speaking to Chris
charla from the ID at Xbox program and
player unknown himself so don't go
anywhere